The Marvel Cinematic Universe adds another
hero to its ranks in "Thor: Love and Thunder,"
as Jane Foster transforms into the Mighty
Thor while battling stage four cancer.
Are fans ready to discuss Jane's fate?
And how does it compare to the comics?
Keep watching to find out.
"Let's bring the rainbow!"
The world-renowned astrophysicist hasn't been
seen in the present-day MCU — aside from
a quick cameo in "Avengers: Endgame" — since
"Thor: The Dark World," and she's back with
a thunderous bang.
Her new Asgardian powers are a shock to Thor
himself, who tries to look at his own place
in the cosmos in something of a mid-life crisis.
When speaking to Fandango, director Taika
Waititi revealed how he convinced Natalie
Portman to return, noting that he wanted to
reinvent the role for the star.
"Her character in those first few films is
probably not the most exciting version of
the female character we want from these films.
[...] I wanted to change that character just
like we'd changed Thor's character for 'Ragnarok'
and give her more license to be adventurous
and fun and funny, 'cause Natalie's a really
funny person."
Foster handles herself well in the fight against
Gorr the God Butcher, who's determined to
slaughter all the gods in the universe, but
she also has to deal with the fact that — as
in the comics — using her powers is effectively
stopping her chemotherapy from doing its job.
It puts Jane in an incredibly difficult position
because although she wants to be there in
the fight, she has to slow down because of
her health.
Ultimately, this leads to an incredibly emotional
finale for Jane and Thor — one that could
lead to something more.
Jane, unfortunately, succumbs to her cancer
in the final battle because the energy she
uses to help Thor fight Gorr drains her strength.
Thankfully, her soul is taken up to Valhalla
in the post-credits scene because she died
on the field of battle — a sign that she's
a true hero.
Obviously, it's a shame that she dies only
one film into her superhero career, but it
is a worthy evolution for the talented scientist.
But is it actually the end?
In the Jason Aaron comics from which parts
of Jane's story in "Thor: Love and Thunder"
were adapted, the focus is on Jane's new identity,
but she does eventually die from her cancer
after saving Asgardia in "Mighty Thor" #706.
As she stands at the gates, though, Odin decides
that her sacrifice is a feat of true heroism
and channels a cosmic thunderstorm to resurrect
her.
A superhero resurrected from death?
In comics?
Surely not!
So yes, it's entirely possible that Jane might
return to the MCU from Valhalla in a future
film.
Whether she should come back from the dead
is another question entirely, because this
wraps up her storyline nicely while honoring
what makes Jane great as a person.
But Marvel always lays the groundwork for
the future, and the Valhalla post-credits
scene isn't there for nothing.
Where could Jane's story in the MCU go next,
though, and what are the chances that Portman
returns to the role?
You might think that after dealing with stage
four cancer, taking on the powers of a Norse
god, and dying valiantly in battle, only to
be revived again by Odin himself, Jane Foster
might be ready to call it quits on her superhero
career.
However, in the world of Marvel Comics, the
character continues to play a noteworthy role
in the action.
She pops up throughout the "War of the Realms"
arc and even assumes the mantle of a Valkyrie
in the aftermath of the bloody interdimensional
battle.
Although the MCU has obviously been forging
its own path through the Marvel canon, using
the comics as inspiration, rather than doctrine,
Jane's robust and continuing story on the
page certainly leaves the door wide open for
her return down the road.
The character's buddy-buddy friendship with
King Valkyrie in "Thor: Love and Thunder"
could be one such conduit for a return, especially
considering Jane's transformation into one
of the Norse ferrywomen in her comics arc.
Of course, she only becomes a Valkyrie after
the others are killed, so if the relationship
between the two characters does bring Jane
back to the MCU, it could end in tragedy.
But we're getting ahead of ourselves.
As far as any future live-action appearances
from Jane are concerned, the real deciding
factor will most likely be whether Natalie
Portman is interested in doing another MCU
film.
After stepping away from the franchise following
2013's "Thor: The Dark World," Taika Waititi
helped convince Portman to return for "Love
and Thunder" by breathing new life into the
character of Jane Foster.
Perhaps with another juicy storyline, Portman
could be convinced to return again.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "Thor:
Love and Thunder" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.